pas tous merci de nous retrouver en
direct sur figaro live ce mardi 20
juillet 2021 nous allons vous faire
vivre le décollage de jeff bezos le
fondateur d'amazon va en effet
participer à un vol historique on peut
le qualifier d'historique effectivement
puisque dans quelques minutes il va
décoller à bord de la fusée mieux
shepard conçu par la société blue origin
société qu'il a lui-même fondé une
actualité qui vous passionne ans et vous
les internautes du figaro alors si vous
avez des questions si vous avez des
commentaires bien vous n'hésitez pas à
nous en faire part sur le chat du figaro
sur figaro l'avait puis sur la chaîne
figurent au live sur youtube évidemment
vous êtes déjà très nombreux
c'est tristan vais journaliste
scientifique au figaro et puis rédacteur
en chef adjoint au service science
médecine qui sera là pour vous qui vous
répondra en direct tout au long de cette
émission que nous allons passer ensemble
et que c'est de cet événement que nous
allons vivre ensemble alors tristan mais
n'est pas encore à mes côtés il ne
saurait tarder il est en chemin il sera
là avec nous dans quelques minutes les
images que nous allons vous diffusée en
direct et ben vous le voyez en ce moment
elle nous proviennent de blue origin
donc la société fondée par jeff bezos
s'ils sont en pleine préparation en ce
moment pour ce décollage qui est prévu à
15 heures heure de paris donc on a le
temps de parler avec vous et de vous
expliquer un peu comment tout ceci va se
dérouler ce sera le premier vol le
premier voyage de tourisme pour blue
origin qui est aussi donc un premier vol
habité
organisé par cette société dédiée au
tourisme spatial
le vol partira ces images elles sont
tournées
nous sommes en direct depuis le
boulevard haussmann dans le 9e
arrondissement de paris mais les images
qu'on vient de vous montrer là en ce
moment en direct et ben vous le voyez
elle nous proviennent du texas d'une
du lieu qui s'appelle van horne qui est
à la frontière avec le mexique
c'est un peu au milieu du désert d'où
partira cette fusée donc je vous le
disais dans 56 minutes et 39 secondes
elle décollera donc en direct pour nous
sur figaro je suis en train de regarder
en même temps ce décompte qui est donc
prévue à 15 heures heure de paris je
voulais déjà dit jeff bezos ce qui devra
décoller mais il décollera pas tout seul
ils seront un certain nombre à bord en
l'occurrence ils seront six seront
quatre pardon en tout il décolle avec
trois autres personnes vous le voyez on
vous a fait un petit visuel réalisé par
raphaël qui est en régie à la fin il a
rasé raffaella lazrag kit réalisateur de
cette émission et qui est en régie en ce
moment il a fabriqué ce super visuel
donc avec le visage de ses passagers qui
prendront leur envol pour l'espace dans
moins d'une heure maintenant jeff bezos
ce bien sûr mais également son frère
marc bezos son frère cadet frère cadet
de l'ex pdg d'amazon qui n'est pas un
milliardaire comme jeff bezos mais il
n'en est pas moins millionnaire il y
aura également à bord wally funk
en fait c'est un surnom puisqu'elle
s'appelle marie wallace funk elle a 82
ans et une pilote émérite qui a tenté à
de nombreuses reprises de d'intégrer la
nasa et de faire des vols en tant qu
astronautes
eh bien ce sera l'occasion cette fois ci
pour elle de le faire elle est là la
plus vieille astronautes à se rendre
dans l'espace quand le vol sera achevé à
ses côtés à leurs côtés vous le voyez un
tout jeune homme 18 ans oliver démène
oliver dimon s'est c'est un astronaute
plutôt jeune puisqu'il est le plus jeune
astronaute de l'histoire il décollera
donc tout à l'heure à partir de 15
heures aux côtés de jeff mais ils ne
sont que quatre à s'envoler sur une
capsule qui je crois le contenir six
passagers et faire voler donc six
touristes de l'espace dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois vous
voyez est la navette
le vaisseau spatial ou la fusée new
shepard blue origin est sur son pas de
tir encore dans une légère pénombre
c'est le soleil qui se lève en ce moment
à van horne au texas
la fusée est censé partir dans 54
minutes et 30 secondes maintenant on
vivra en direct avec à mes côtés tristan
vais vous le connaissez bien maintenant
journaliste scientifique au figaro je
vous laisse apprécier ces images qui
sont magnifiques
on
vous voyez ces images tournées à on
dirait que tu es capturés depuis van
horne au texas doudou doit décoller dans
moins d'une heure le vaisseau spatial la
fusée nous shepard de la société blue
origin société fondée par jeff bezos ce
le milliardaire ex pdg d'amazon doit
prendre place à bord de cette navette
aux côtés de son frère et puis aux côtés
d'un jeune homme de 18 ans plus jeune
astronaute de l'histoire de l'histoire
de l'espace et aux côtés également de
walle funk et dont vous voilez vous
voyez la photo en ce moment 82 ans donc
la plus ancienne des astronautes et le
plus jeune des astronautes se
partageront cet événement et garderont
en mémoire cet événement après ce vol
qui doit partir dans moins d'une heure
jeff bezos ce sera aux côtés également
de son frère on andra attristant vert
pourquoi ce choix d'avoir son frère à
ses côtés
pour ce vol dont on disait qu'il est
historique puisque c'est une première
pour la société blue origin qui se
lancent dans le tourisme de l'espace le
tourisme spatial
c'est le premier vol habité organisé par
cette société qui va dédier ces
prochains vols à ce tourisme qui
permettra à des passagers comme vous et
moi mais
probablement beaucoup plus
financièrement pour but d'aller faire un
tour de quelques minutes dans l'espace
le décollage est prévu à 15 heures heure
de paris vous l'avez vue sur ces images
la fusée est encore sur son pâtir dans
une légère pennant puisque le soleil se
lève à peine au texas nous serons
rejoints dans quelques minutes par le
spécialiste de l'espace et des fusée qui
décolle tristan vrai journaliste
scientifique au figaro il ne devrait
plus tarder maintenant il nous a promis
d'être là avant 14h15
il est donc en chemin on imagine que
vous avez des questions à nous poser des
commentaires vous nous fait à nous faire
donc vous n'hésitez pas nous sommes là
pour vous vous pouvez le faire depuis le
site figaro.fr figaro live et le chat
qui a été mis en place
et puis nous sommes également présents
pour cette diffusion directe sur le
conte et la chaîne youtube de figaro
live vous vous êtes déjà très nombreux à
nous suivre et vivre cet événement en
direct donc jeff bezos ce décollera à 15
heures avec trois autres passagers à son
bord au bo à bord de son vaisseau
spatial un rêve d'enfant at il souvent
exprimée ces dernières semaines au cours
des interviews qu'il a données aux
médias américains étrangers vous le
voyez ce décompte 1 50 minutes avant le
décollage
je crois que les passagers ne sont pas
encore installés dans la capsule que
vous voyez au sommet de cette fusée
on aura les explications détaillées de
tristan vert sur ce vol et la façon dont
ils veulent se dérouler une fusée
décollera avec à son sommet cette
capsule au cours du vol la fusée va se
détacher la capsule va se détacher de
cette fusée qui logiquement et parce
qu'elle est réutilisable reuse 0 elle
sera de retour sur terre quelques
minutes après et puis les passagers de
ce vol historique seront également de
retour sur terre quelques minutes à
peine après avoir pu observer la terre
depuis l'espace
cette fusée nous shepard qui a une
magnifique plume noire dessinée sur
l'extérieur quand je ne sais pas si on
peut parler de carlingue de la fusée en
tout cas sur son fuselage
si vous voulez d'ailleurs tout
comprendre
la façon dont va décoller cette fusée
comment elle est équipée comment les
éléments vont se séparer et bien je vous
renvoie sur le formidable travail fait
par les équipes du fiqh data et qui est
en ligne vous pouvez voir ce petit cette
petite animation que vous montre raphaël
lazreg notre réalisateur en régie qui
vous montrent qu'à fabriquer le figaro
et le service fixe data pour tout
comprendre de ce vol et de la façon dont
français de 7,6 et dont on peut voir
voilà sur cette animation
cette plume noire qui l'habille et qui
est le symbole de blue origin formidable
travail je le disais des équipes du fils
data vous le voyez c'est accessible
depuis le site lefigaro.fr
avec cette animation et voilà on voit là
la fusée qui retourne qui retourne sur
terre on reviendra sur cette animation
du fiqh data qui vous permet de tout
comprendre
l'animation interactive vous pouvez en
passant la souris sur les différents
éléments qui composent ce visuel avoir
des explications propres à chacune des
parties de se dérouler que vient de vous
montrer notre réalisateur en régie que
je remercie rafael lazreg pour ce petit
visuel
voilà détaillé vous êtes très nombreux à
nous suivre sur le chat de youtube sur
et des questions on composera à un autre
expert tristan va qui ne saurait tarder
maintenant pour répondre à vos questions
certains demande effectivement combien
coûte un voile comme celui ci ce sont
des questions effectivement qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous se pose
combien coûte un vol comme celui ci
et beaucoup de questions en rapport
également avec avec l'écologie et la
problématique de la pollution générée
par l'envoi d'une fusée commun comme
celle ci on se souvient il ya quelques
jours à peine le 11 juillet dernier
c'est un concurrent mundo jeff bezos
c'est un autre milliardaire très connu
également richard bronson qui a pris son
envol à bord cette fois ci mais pas
d'une fusée mais d'un avion un avion
spatial et lui aussi est allé voir et
toucher les étoiles
le 11 juillet dernier on en parlerait
avec ti strombeek in our joie à
l'instant merci stream store mais c'est
pas grave vous avez pris une fusée pour
arriver donc vous êtes dans les temps
merci d'être ici je rappelle vous êtes
journaliste scientifique au figaro
rédacteur en chef adjoint du service
sciences et médecine au figaro vous êtes
notre expert des spécialistes des
étoiles des fusées de l'espace et vous
allez pouvoir répondre à nos internautes
qui sont nombreux on disait vous quand
vous voyez des images comme celles ci
vous en avez l'habitude on le voit cette
fusée sur son pas de tir
un rêve d'enfant de jeff bezos ce qui se
concrétise aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
peut on dire déjà que c'est une petite
fusée elle fait que 15 m
de haut ce qui est assez petit 1 15
mètre faut voir c'est un immeuble de
cinq étages d'un immeuble haussmannien à
peu près alors ça peut avoir l'air grand
comme ça vous l'avouer dans la rue vous
imaginez bon quelque chose de cette
taille là qui fait qu'ils tutoient les
les toits de paris
mais la fusée par exemple falcon 9 de
space x qui est la fusée courante ou
fait 70 mètres de haut ariane 5 a fait
55 ou 60 mètres de haut sont cinq
peut-être même se dépenser configuration
mais donc c'est 4 à 5 fois plus grand
donc ça c'est quand même un tout petit
un tout petit une toute petite fusée
néanmoins elle est bourrée de
technologie on aura l'occasion d'en
parler un peu et la voilà on est on est
au petit matin donc ces salaires un
petit peu nuageux comme ça est un peu de
brume je découvre en même temps que vous
voilà la grande matinale dans le désert
nantes à son pays qui ne saurait à qui
serait alors à priori ça vole a priori
je ne pense pas là on voit que le le
compte à rebours est toujours à 45
minutes donc il n'y a pas de problème on
n'a pas d'info en l'état sur des noms et
si son petit matis exactement il y ait
encore les prisons météo étaient très
bonnes
il faut savoir qu'en gros pour les laits
lancement il ya deux choses qui peuvent
perturber un lancement il ya la foudre
évidemment même si des paratonnerres
tout autour des du site généralement
j'ai pas vu moi généralement il ya des
paratonnerres un peu autour
et sinon c'est l'élève en haute altitude
voilà les vents aux altitudes ça c'est
un problème pour la trajectoire
là c'était comment les vents en altitude
avec des ballons oui ça il ya des
ballons-sondes donc on arrive à savoir
un peu quels sont les quelles sont les
conditions en levant au sol est
généralement pas trop dérangeant mais
c'est plutôt en l'air ça peut avoir une
à une
ça peut mettre en péril on va dire
l'attraction de la fusée alors là en
l'occurrence comme si je suis fusée qui
monte qui redescend je pense que les
conditions atmosphériques sont a priori
encore moins importante
voilà faut juste monter et redescendre
après il faut récupérer le lanceur que
ses premiers vols habités je pense qu'il
prendrait pas de risques inconsidérés
on va y revenir sur les étapes de ce vol
en détail
je salue en ce moment les internautes du
figaro qui se sont connectés sur le chat
du figaro.fr figaro live cam kamilou
bonjour yoyo tata tout coeur et puis
d'ailleurs à propos de came kamilou on
le disait un quatre passagers vont
prendre
leur envol si je puis dire aux côtés
dans ces quatre incluant jeff bezos
c'est jeff bezos son frère un jeune
homme de 18 ans et une dame de 82 ans
une des pilotes émérites on les voit sur
ces images ces pilotes ils vont entrer
dans la navette
cam kamilou elle demande qui est ce
jeune homme qui par an rappelle qu'il
n'a que 18 ans qui est il alors son nom
m'échappe
c'est le fils en fait d'un du fondateur
et si odin d'un grand groupe d'un grand
fonds spéculatifs qui avait participé
aux enchères qui avait organisé début
juin me semble-t-il c'est des enchères
donc que kébé vocation à être reversés à
des oeuvres caritatives
l'idée c'était de vendre un ticket sur
ce premier vol inaugural
là le wali funky invité donc cesser la
pilote on en reparlera peut-être 400 à 2
ans jeff bezos a invité son frère qui
est aussi son meilleur ami je crois que
c'est un peu ça le on n'est pas monté et
la halle et voilà il ya un peu de retard
du coup il ya eu ta voix je pense que
c'est là le sens du hb - adopter
d'autres endroits tarder
ouais ça nous montrer dans un dans les
quatre heures en fait je pense que la la
la la fusée ouais en pointe en principe
la timeline officiel c'était rentrer
dans la capsule 45 minutes avant le
décollage
je me casserais nombre de procédures une
fois que les gens sont à bord de
vérification etc
on n'est pas maître des bagages je sais
pas
des petites choses avec lesquelles ils
vont ils vont être là quand ce volet
ouais c'est ça peut être un petit peu
dubaï a quand même une heure à patienter
avant le le décollage et avant une
vingtaine de minutes avant que avant que
avant que l'on ferme en fête le la porte
donc c'est à témoin 24 minutes je crois
qu'on qui vont fermer de la porte je
pense que cette chronologie là doit être
un petit peu rigide et donc comme ils
sont pas encore montés dans la capsule
ça veut dire qu'il ya quelques minutes
de retard donc là le temps d'y aller
dont tu es dedans on va voir ça plairait
d'être un retard trop important qu'ils
soient liés à autre chose que juste
voilà peut être un petit aléa de 2,2
programmatique le temps d'aller aux
toilettes ça peut être vraiment des
choses je traiterai pas rien très mineur
je présume
on le disait tristan c'est une un vol
historique
on peut le qualifier comme ça d'abord
c'est le premier vol habité de 7,7
entreprises cette société blue origin et
puis en même temps il y a yoyo tata qui
nous dit je crois si c'est bien elle
danse et aux choeurs pardon tankers sur
le chef du figaro qui nous rappelle que
le drapeau américain a été mis sur la
lune le 21 juillet 1969
oui c'est pas du tout innocent d'avoir
choisi c'est un jeu c'est le 20 juillet
fête heure américaine ces matières
juillet pour nous en france que mieux de
la nuit mais c'était le souverain s'est
elle donc c'est beau la date officielle
c'est le 20 juillet pour les américains
c'est pas le 21 le 21 c'est parce que
c'est pour notre heure de greenwich
voulu ici référence à agir sur la lune
oui c'est certain
c'est symbolique quitte à faire le vol
cet été autant le faire le 20 juillet il
et on lui a grillé la politesse à
charbon ne sonne de manière
certains ont trouvé que ce n'était pas
très pas très
pas très fair d'avoir d'avoir contacté
la politesse après que le trait annoncé
sa date et c2 de faire son nom sur neuf
jours avant le rappel griller la
politesse
richard branson
virgin atlantic lactique pardon qui a
décollé le 11 juillet dernier loué
d'ailleurs il ya tata qui nous précise
que
l'avion de richard branson est monté à
85 km d'altitude celui de jeff bezos
c'est une fusée qui montent à plus de
cent kilomètres c'est quoi la différence
concrètement concrètement en vérité
presqu'aucune c'est une espèce de
bisbilles dayraut spatiale mais en gros
la ligne de karmann ça qui fixe la lie
la frontière théorique entre l'espace et
la terre et a été fixé à 100 km de
manière un peu arbitraire tout ça c'est
un compte rond en gros c'est la distance
à partir de laquelle l'atmosphère est à
peu près négligeable mais savoir si dire
qu'on est vraiment dans l'espace voilà
dans le vide de l'espace mais il faut
savoir c'est que la station spatiale qui
est à 400 km d'altitude par exemple on
voit là non 5 à fait
jeff bezos ça à wall-e funk 7,7 pilote
émérite on en parlera dans quelques
minutes sept pilotes de 82 ans qui est
du coup de fait la plus vieille
astronautes si on peut dire ça comme ça
c'est pas très élégant à s'envoler pour
l'exploration la plus ancienne voie la
mairie ce temps on la voit elle est en
pleine forme pour pour s'envoler dans
quelques minutes maintenant en 42
minutes et on voit ce suv qui se dirige
avec ses quatre passagers à son bord
vers le pâtir de la fusée de jeff bezos
ce nous séparent de blue origin qui
devrait s'envoler d'ici mois dans moins
de trois quarts d'heure maintenant
tristan va nous et qu'ils ont un petit
peu de retard quelques minutes à peine
ouais mais ils ont repris la vive allure
il
ils ont repris le
la timeline on voit que en gros ce qui
ce qui compte c'est tout en aidant les
vols cette timeline là qui défilent la
cause qu'on appelle la chronologie temps
qu'elle se déroule
ça veut dire que tout se passe à peu
près correctement quand elle s'arrête
c'est qu'il ya un ça peut être un souci
ça peut être ça peut être des fois trois
fois rien mais ça veut dire que voilà on
arrête la chronologie parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de choses à faire avant
de lancer une fusée qui sont qui
demandent un temps incompressible
il faut notamment remplir les réservoirs
donc on remplit au dernier moment
surtout dans ce cas-là ou cdd dans les
carburants on pourra y revenir mais
cryogénique s'est maintenu à très basse
température c'est de l'oxygène liquide
et de l'hélium de l'hydrogène liquide
pour les maintenir liquide ils sont
cryogénisé c'est ça c'est 1000 sont
maintenus à très basse température wayne
qui sont voilà donc ça on
en fait contrairement à remplir les
réservoirs il faut les maintenir froid
il ya de l'échappement qui se passe donc
faut continuellement approvisionner le
réservoir donc on ne sait pas trop
longtemps avant le départ du vol sinon
ça coûterait très cher et puis voilà
c'est quand même des notamment le
l'hydrogène c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas qui est pas anodin à manipuler
donc voilà on essaye au minimum de ne
pas mettre la poudre dans le pétard bien
sûr il vaut mieux dans ces cas là alors
il ya un certain nombre d'internautes
qui se moque des mois à oui j'ai utilisé
l'expression vieille astronautes donc je
vois assez hmm qui se moque et puis
djoko ce qui nous dit que 80 2 ans est
magnifique mais bien sûr que c'est
magnifique
voilà l'un ce trail intel astronautes la
plus âgée me corrige qui était sur ses
futurs astronautes ils ne sont as trop
d'eau que quand ils seront revenus sur
terre et qu'ils auront fait un tour dans
l'espace on disait jeff bezos sera
accompagné de son frère marc bezos ce
pourquoi at il voulu que son frère soit
à ses côtés au bois parce qu'ils sont
très proches je crois après je suis pas
dans la je suis pas dans son intimité
particulière et pour tout dire voilà je
pense pas que ce soit trop notre rôle
mais je de ce qu'il en dit voilà son
frère et un peu son meilleur ami donc je
pense qu'il avait envie de partager ce
moment c'est assez
quand on pense ce qu'on veut me
personnage super est attendue en matière
du du du milliardaire
de l'homme d'affaires si on veut après
chacun à chacun a son opinion je suis
pas la main après l'homme en tant que
tel il n'y a pas de raison de douter
particulièrement du fait que c'est un
rêve de gosse quoi c'est un rêve
d'enfant il a toujours eu envie d'aller
dans l'espace
il a des idées sur la poursuite en suite
de la conquête spatiale là la manière
dont l'humanité doit doit coloniser
l'espace proche pour continuer à
progresser et c'est là encore chacun
chacun peut on y reviendra un jour mardi
à y croire mais elles sont elles sont je
pense sincère mais différente d'ailleurs
de décès de richard barrett de brandson
différentes d'elon musk
j'ai une question pour vous à tristan
base et c'est lucky luke à à 17 bonjour
tristan dit il commet un petit réacteur
comme celui de la fusée peut la faire
décoller dans l'espace c'est une
question sur le chat alors c'est pas un
petit réacteur c'est un moteur-fusée
donc c'est sympa c'est un vrai moteur
fusée qui apparemment très bien conçu un
jeu
moi même je n'ai pas les compétences
pour ans pour juger mais les
interlocuteurs qu'on peut qu'on a pu
avoir sur le sujet ne vis que c'est un
moteur très bien fait qui fonctionne
très bien qui a l'air très fiable le
principe d'un moteur fusée par rapport à
une turbine c'est en fait on utilise le
carburant enfin le gaz de combustion
qu'on va expulser et c'est vraiment
l'expulsion de ce gaz qui va va faire
décoller la fuite générique vous tous et
voilà on n'utilise pas l'air ambiant à
une turbine
elle va aussi créer de la combustion ces
hausses les gaz de combustion mais il y
aura une grande partie
de la poussée qui va être générée grâce
à l'air ambiant
or quand on atteint 30 km à peu près
même au delà de 10 20 km on a plus assez
d'air pour avancer et donc du coup il
faut avoir en fait faut embarquer l'air
avec soi si on veut d'une certaine façon
est donc c'est le combustible qui va
faire ça le principe du moteur fusée on
voit les quatre passagers qui sont en
train de gravir ces escaliers qui n'en
finissent pas doivent cette idole c'est
à dire que ça ne finit pas avant
d'arriver à la capsule au sommet placé
au sommet de cette fusée blue origin
on voit que la mise en scène a quand
même été travaillée way travailler mais
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec le voilà
ce qu'est ce qui a pu faire justement se
paye six spéciales ce qui est un peu de
vent dans tous les domaines par rapport
à jeff bezos ce en termes de design de
fusées d'avancement de financements
obtenus auprès de la nasa d'un complice
m'enfin bon là c'est qu'ils sont ils
sont partis ensemble mais sur sept duels
dont vous parlez en
évidemment mais bien non même en termes
de de mise en scène
et alors ça peut paraître anecdotique
mais je pense qu'il ya une dimension de
comment dire de l anneau ce qui est une
manière de penser un peu à tout et de
mettre les choses en scène qui voilà qui
est assez c'est assez spectaculaire et
qui attire en fait les jeunes et du coup
ça ils arrivent en fait à attirer tous
les meilleurs ingénieurs tous les par
sept par ce sens du spectacle 7
cette ambition qui monte extra qu'on
peut critiquer mais ça fait rêver les
jeunes et donc c'est une conséquence
très direct c'est qu'il attire les plus
grands talents et que du coup il arrive
à faire les choses les plus
spectaculaires c'est pas du sepa sepa
complètement anodin c'est pas gratuit
mais je me dis ouais c'est du marketing
mais en fait c'est dans le sens où l'on
fêtera tjcc du marketing mais en fait
c'est 70 de l'image pour nous qu'il a un
space x à côté sexy et ça attire les
jeunes les jeunes talents la même
manière que toute la conquête spatiale
dans les années 60 a attiré à la nasa
tous les plus grands cerveaux de
l'époque et ça a permis tout cette
conquête spatiale de voilà d'avoir d
accomplissement incroyable
donc cette capacité à faire rêver elle
n'est pas du tout anodine et il faut je
pense s'en inspirer vous parliez de ce
duel
cette concurrence on va dire entre elon
musk et puis jeff bezos ça va je vous
renvoie évidemment sur le site du
figaro.fr et dans le papier le print du
figaro dans les kiosques depuis ce matin
et le papier formidable papier de
véronique guillermard notre spécialiste
aéronautique d osmose qu'un duel
spatiale encore déséquilibré je vous le
recommande fortement alors qu'on voit en
ce moment sur ces images tournées depuis
le texas et le pas de tir d'où doit
décoller la navette
de jeff bezos ce biseau ce qui marche
jusqu'à cette capsule
alors ce qu'il faut dire vaisseau
spatial capsule fusée comment on doit
appeler cet ensemble que l'on voit sur
le pas de tir
l'ensemble s'est tue c'est clairement
une fusée après ce qui a donc en haut de
la fusée c'est plutôt une capsule mais
on peut tout à fait appeler une capsule
un vaisseau spatial
il n'y a pas de problème vaisseau
spatial c'est un terme générique capsule
c'est interne un peu plus on peut plus
on va dire technique mais c'est le so
you c'est une capsule donc c'est le
déçoit au russe
il ya le ratio s'établit en soit
considéré que c'est un vaisseau oui
c'est sa façon spéciale mais ça pourrait
être la navette d'un vaisseau spatial
aussi lenteur price de star trek est
aussi un vaisseau spatial on est fan de
séries tv plutôt sur une est là c'est
aussi un vaisseau spatial dans sa
version la plus peut-être radeau de
sauvetage si on la compare à ce qu'on
peut trouver dans la sf mais c'est à peu
près ce qu'on sait faire de mieux
aujourd'hui
les capsules celle là présente à 1 une
particularité c'est d'avoir des hublots
extrêmement grand et donc ça c'est
directement lié à son son objectif c'est
de faire du tourisme spatial donc que
des gens puissent regarder par la
fenêtre
j'en parle avec jean françois clervoy
qu'un ancien trop de français et
j'adorerais faire un temps cette capsule
parce que les hublots fontainois voilà
qui est lui la veille à bord de la
navette spatiale américaine
et voilà les les les hiboux sont plus
petits donc ils trouvent ça ils trouvent
ça c'est chouette alors après bon c'est
pas du tout la même ambition mais du
coup ça et voilà les faits de faux après
un mètre de haut et 110 de large
voilà très ouest c'est beaucoup plus
grand que votre hublot de l'avion par
exemple louis toujours trempé ça
ressemble plus ils se ressemblent tous à
une fenêtre va dire de deux maisons
quasiment et donc du mois la voiture que
je pense qu'il y aura des caméras à
l'intérieur mais je pense qu'on devait
avoir des vues un peu de ce que voient
les passagers qui sont allongés en qui
sont agréables que dans un transat
transat de valence de plage d une gêne
au nom d'une marque parce que ça
ressemble vraiment à ça mais iota
s'interroge sur le chat du figaro sur
lefigaro.fr je l'en remercie
ça reste quand même un gros pétard sous
les fesses dit il où dit elle
effectivement on voit ce cette capsule 1
au sommet de cette fusée dont vous
disiez que elle était équipée avec des
gaz cryogénisé pour rester liquide à
très basse température qui est une bombe
en puissance un potentiellement oui
c'est ça c'est un c'est vraiment ça
c'est un c'est un pétard ça une grosse
force et là c'est une toute petite fusée
néanmoins la force de pousser qu'on
ressent a pas grand chose à voir avec la
puissance de la fusée elle même parce
qu'en fait bon après ça s'est un petit
peu technique mais bon on peut entrer en
détails techniques mais en gros une
fusée au décollage rejoindre sa poussée
elle est tellement lourde donc elle
développe énormément de puissance pour
s'arracher au sol l'accélération est
relativement modeste beaucoup beaucoup
plus faible que ce qu'on peut imaginer
en fait c'est comparable à quelque chose
qu'on pourrait ressentir en voyant
voiture qui accélère très vite
l'accélération elle devient beaucoup
plus forte en fait quand on commence à
sortir de l'atmosphère et donc ça c'est
une ode à de 30 km 20 30 km l'air se
raréfie
voilà au premier des petits
les fusée à plusieurs étages c'est
souvent avec le deuxième étage que la
poussée la plus forte parce qu'à ce
moment là même si le moteur est beaucoup
moins puissant la fusée beaucoup plus
légère la résistance de l'air est
beaucoup moins forte de l'accélération
est beaucoup plus brutale et donc les
passages c'est là qu'on monte jusqu'à 3
g 3 4 3 kg ça veut dire quatre fois
l'appui le poids de cette façon qu à son
corps et c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
ressentir dans un manège un peu fort un
peu incongru que les deux voilà mais
sait on se rapproche de sa et donc voilà
on peut le dire les fautes
s'entraînant centrifugeuses oui c'est
pas quelque chose de très extrême
là je sais pas si vous avez eu un
accident en f1 par exemple ce week-end
voilà vers semaine est rentré dans les
bâches et son discours sur le choc
il a ressenti 50 g kwh à 55 ans il a
complètement cédé très protégée et sur
un temps très bref oui la c3 3,4 g sur
plusieurs dizaines de secondes
là c'était vraiment au monde l'impact
mais juste pour dire qu' il faut
relativiser c'est pour relativiser parce
qu'ils sont aussi entraîné pour ça c'est
pour ça qu'une personne de 81 2 on peut
tout à fait voyager et ressentir ces
poussées et encaissé ccg à 30 ans qu'on
les a trois quatre cinq ans fait enfin
faut être quand même un petit peu en
bonne santé mais oui elle a l'air ne
connaissez pas le principal écueil de
santé c'est le sait le coeur en fête
oui et c'est pas tant liée à la
spécificité vol spécial c'est comme pour
un saut en parachute on vous demande de
faire un électrocardiogramme avant c'est
pas parce que le son parachute nécessite
d'avoir un très bon coeur c'est juste
que l'appréhension du moment peut vous
faire monter le coeur amputation très
rapide très rapide et donc si vous êtes
si vous avez une fragilité une tendance
à faire de la rétine etc
vous pouvez avoir un accident cardiaque
elles sont là mais c'est plus lié à
l'excitation finalement
à l'adrénaline que vous allez avoir un
risque malgré tout d'embarquer cette
femme de 82 ans elle est certainement en
très bonne forme elle est aguerri aux je
voulais 17 une pilote chevronné un qui a
formé elle-même de nombreux pilotes de
de très hautes compétences
elle a quand même 82 ans vous le dites
il ya une accélération du rythme
cardiaque est le stress
ouais ça me sens mieux je sais pas
n'importe qui il n'a pas pris les palets
prendre la première grand mère de 82 ans
il a croisé dans la rue il a pris une
ancienne pilote d'essai qui a une longue
carrière aéronautique derrière elle qui
étaient là qui était la première femme
dans de nombreux à de nombreux postes
dans l'aéronautique
voilà c'est sais c'est qu'il a failli
elle elle a failli alors c'est une
histoire un peu compliquée parce que
c'est
c'est un programme de la nasa mais 1/2
programme de la nasa en fait c'est le
médecin qui recrutait les astronaute du
programme mercury 7 les sept astronautes
qui en parallèle à mener une campagne de
recrutement chez les femmes
mais la nasa entre temps avait dit avait
limité finalement l'accès au statut des
astronautes au seul pilote d'essai
militaire
or
il y avait interdiction pour les femmes
d'être pilote d'essai militaire
donc du coup ça entrée en alors après ce
que la nation est servi un peu comme
excuse pourquoi ne voulez pas faire
entrer des fans dans son programme
bon le on va dire que le monde a
beaucoup changé en 60 ans et c'est une
et c'est heureux en tout cas elle a eu
en tout cas au lit quand la nasa a
regretté ne pas avoir été recruté par la
nasa pour voler quant à nathan réalise
un rêve là exactement et quand la nasa a
pris ça elle a appris que le médecin
faisait ça elle a annulé ce programme
donc pas de femme astronaute avant
encore très longtemps je n'ai plus à
d'après pham astronomes et ça ça me
bouffe ou telle ambiance années 80 ouais
ça ne veut plus de 20 ans et voilà et du
coup là c'est un peu la revanche elle va
elle pourrait devenir donc là son épouse
âgée est que le ce record est détenu
actuellement par un homme à l'asnl n 77
en 98 il est passé neuf jours
c'est une mission de la navette spatiale
américaine discovery je crois mais je
suis pas certain voilà des à 77 ans
c'est depuis pour le décollage de la
navette et 9 jours en orbite c'est
encore un peu plus encore un peu plus
encore un peu autre chose
alors quand il s'agit vraiment d'un
aller retour un généreux oui on va on va
le voir sur le détail de ce vol on va on
va expliquer exactement quoi ils
consistent les quatre passagers dont qui
viennent d'être installés dans cette
capsule perché au sommet de cette fusée
blue origin
nous sépare d'elle s'appelle cette fusée
cette capsule ce vaisseau spatial comme
nous l'a dit tristan vais on a vu les
images de ces quatre passagers juste
avant leur embarquement dans une petite
pièce où il était là en stand by on va
dire et envoyer un jeff bezos s'est un
peu tendue nous dit anonyme 7,57 130 qui
trouvait que ça a l'air tendu on peut
considérer que c'est un peu normal c'est
un événement qui le concerne au plus
près aujourd'hui un sacré défi à relever
pour ce qui le concerne c'est son
entreprise sa société ça fait si je ne
trompe pas vingt ans que cette société a
été fondée qu'elle est dédié au tourisme
spatial
et aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour pour
jeff bezos ce qui s'envole avec son
frère pour ce vol premier vol habité
pour cette cette capsule dans l'espace
un vol très court on va détailler les
étapes de ce vol tristan on va voir avec
raphaël lazreg ci peut nous montrer les
images de ce qu'elle nous a fourni le
fikda tard pour bien comprendre en quoi
va consister ce vol et ce découpage on
voit ces des timing très serré très très
court trois minutes 4 minutes 6 minutes
et puis après on définit exactement
après le le timing précis relativement
approximatif pour la simple et bonne
raison que blue reggina pas vraiment
communiqué
comme comme peut le faire la nasa lors
de ces vols ou space x aussi
généralement on a on a une timeline
extrêmement précises à la seconde près
de toutes les opérations de vol voilà
mon blues rudy n'a pas n'a pas dévoilé
précisément donc on a dû se contenter un
peu d informations qui ont qui en
filtrer après il ya des lois de
mécanique orbitale qui font ainsi que en
termes de timing
une fois que le moteur est coupé c'est à
dire ou trois minutes environ il ya plus
trop de mystère sur le temps qu'ils sont
cons mais pour arriver en haut de la
cloche comme quand on lance une balle un
faut s'imaginer ça le le bas de la fusée
c'est un peu la main qui lance la balle
elle va pousser pendant 3 minutes
environ
au bout de deux minutes les les
les passagers devrait déjà commencer à
voir le noir de l'espace le ciel ils
sont en plein jour et il est néanmoins
quand ils regarderont vers le haut le
ciel sera noir il sera bleu quand il
regarde vers l'horizon et ils verront
ensuite le en dessous le texas
au bout de deux trois minutes environ
le la capsule va se séparer de la fusée
qui va à prix qui va éteindre son son
moteur à partir de ce moment là la
capsule et c'est comme une balle qu'on a
jetée en l'air vous pouvez faire
l'expérience à dire avec un prenez un
pot de confiture vide
mettez trois grains de riz dedans et
l'enseignement en l'air vous allez voir
que les grains de riz vont comme flotter
un peu dans le dans le vert dans le dans
le dans le pot en fait voilà dans le
référentiel du pot ils sont là ils sont
plus vraiment solide c'est quand vous
lancez trois balles en même temps avec
votre main elle se sépare l'une des
autres assez naturellement
voilà quand on est en chute libre en
fait on n'est plus complètement
on ressent plus vraiment le ça veut dire
que d'aggraver pendant quelques secondes
quelques minutes à peine ils seront en
apesanteur ses quatre passagers ils sont
en apesanteur jusqu'à ce que les jusqu'à
ce que le le jusqu'à ce que la capsule
le retour dans l'atmosphère
et là c'est les forces de frottement
de l'air qui vont qui vont vraiment
ralentir donc faire desserrer la capsule
et c'est ça qui va imagine qu'ils
feraient de la capsule à son retour sur
terre président des parachutes j'espère
a quasiment que ça et des parachutes sur
la fin et peut-être aussi nom alors je
trouvais desservant toute fin c'est
vraiment c'est un sombre est il
tomberait à 10km rosol 6 serait un peu
brutale oui
aubin enfin c'est ce que c'est
typiquement ce qui se passe avec une
capsule soyouz on tombe au sol mais
l'américain un peu rugueuse mais là il y
avait là des petites refusé pour essayer
de d'amortir encore un peu le choc pour
que ce soit un peu plus un peu plus doux
et les parachutes qui vont évidemment
freiner une fois qu'on est en
relativement basse altitude voyait assez
d'air en fait pour déployer des ddd
parachute mais il ya une bonne partie de
la décélération qui se fait quand même
déjà de par les frottements de masse
ferrique alors moins que pour un retour
non l'habitat orbite a demandé ils ne
vont pas être soumis à ses très hautes
températures et être n'ont quasiment pas
beaucoup moins que quand j'ai pas la
vitesse exacte en tête malheureusement
mais il pour la vitesse de libération
ces onze kilomètres par seconde donc un
vol orbital
voilà formulaire 3600 ça fait ça fait
cinq fois dit ça fait trente-cinq mètres
à peu près donc là ça va très très vite
il ya elle est équipée cette capsule
d'un bouclier thermique on imagine même
s'il ya des fenêtres assez grande pour
surmonter un petit boîtier thermique en
dessous et probablement pour absorber
les frottements mais je pense pas que ce
soit quelque chose c'est que c'est
quelque chose qui est relativement
paris un petit bouquet terme et quoi
évidemment mais ccc on n'est pas dans
les mêmes on n'est quand même pas dans
les mêmes régimes que pour une rentrée
une rentrée d'un vol orbital
cela se passait pas encore les mêmes
technologies
si vous venez nous rejoindre en direct
sur figaro l'arrivée sur youtube nous
sommes en train de vous faire vivre le
décollage du milliardaire ex pdg
d'amazon jeff bezos ce qui est d'ores et
déjà installée dans cette capsule blue
origin nous shepard au sommet de cette
fusée qui est en ce moment sur son pâtir
dans un désert du texas à la frontière
avec le mexique
on attend ce décollage qui est prévue
d'ici une toute petite vingtaine de
minutes
il est prévu à 15 heures heure de paris
jeff bezos qui s'est installée et qui
s'est assis aux côtés de son frère marc
b dos d'un jeune garçon de 18 ans qui
devrait devenir le plus jeune astronaute
de l'histoire il n'a que 18 ans et puis
de l'astronaute qui deviendra la femme
la plus capée est la plus ancienne la
plus je sais pas la pluie seniors on va
dire well i phone dont on voit la photo
sur ce visuel fabriqués par notre
réalisateur raphaël lazreg nous allons
vous faire vivre cet événement vous êtes
avec nous depuis trois quarts d'heure
maintenant vous êtes nombreux à poser
vos questions et poster vos commentaires
sur notre chatte et bien oui vous avez
énormément de questions sur la sécurité
pour votre sécurité justement tristan
comme l'aviation civile
des normes et qui est obligé de se se
restreint des se contraindre à obéir aux
normes imposées par par l'aviation
civile
est ce que jeff bezos ce richard branson
elon musk également son à ces règles
alors je connais pas le détail mais je
présume que oui il y aura des normes
anti-incendie des normes de des normes
de sécurité voilà je pense que tu dois
pas très différente de celle de
l'aéronautique
voilà après c'est plutôt des questions
d'assurances quoi comment fonctionne
l'appareil je pense qu'ils sont tenus
d'avoir un système d'assurance pour les
pour les personnes qui qui qui voyagent
de décharge et ces voix là mais je pense
pas qu'ils aient de nanterre ne sait pas
les autorités officielles en tout cas
comme la f1 je états unis je sais pas
comment comment ça fonctionne ce que
c'est pratiquement en en revenant des
zones un peu grise parce que je sais que
la nasa tv qu'on pour ces vols habités
de monde tout un nombre de règles de
sécurité qu'elle impose aux gens à quel
commandes des capsules ou quand elles
problème ces capsules
là en l'occurrence la jeff bezos ça n'a
aucun compte à rendre à la nasa on est
d'accord ils ne sont pas liées à la nasa
d'une façon ou d'une autre il gère son
son vol
la fabrication de sa navette voilà après
il ya des raisons de son vaisseau en
autonomie totale on va dire il ya des
choses on va dire de
de de bon sens mais typiquement
l'avantagé d'être sur une fusée
l'avantagé de connaître une fusée
l'inconvénient c'est que c'est un moteur
fusée par nature un moteur fusée a
explosé de temps en temps
on sait pas forcément toujours
exactement pourquoi mais il ya des
accidents ça arrive
l'histoire l'a montré et du coup quand
on fait voler des vols habités avec une
capsule
il ya un système assez simple qui
consiste à équiper la capsule de moteurs
pour qu'en cas d'explosion elle pu
s'éjecter très rapidement c'est à dire
dans ces circonstances là que finalement
le le l'accélération est le plus la plus
violente parce que le la capsule est pas
très lourd dont l'une un grand coup de
un grand coup déjections sap a été
utilisé beaucoup dans l'histoire mais
c'est utile et récemment avec deux un
vaisseau soyouz où il ya eu une avarie
sur le lanceur et le système d'éjection
de la capsule a parfaitement fonctionné
a sauvé la vie des passagers
ils pourraient s'injecter les quatre
passagers de la cale sous la capot ne
peut s'éjecter eux mêmes le même ne
peuvent pas s'éjecter et d'ailleurs je
je crois que sur virgin galactic pour
coup il ya aucun système il ya aucun
système de
de sauvegarde quoi ils peuvent pas à
s'extraire de l'avion et sautez eux
mêmes en parachute
je crois que la vie étant donné la
physionomie de l'avion c'est pas comme
un vaisseau de chasse qu'on peut enlever
le hublot jours pour s'éjecter a merdé
là il ya un plafond je crois pas que
cueillez cette possibilité là du tout
alors on vous vous l'expliquer tout à
l'heure la fusée donc va partir avec au
sommet la capsule on le voit sur ces
images cette fusée qui est ce vaisseau
qui est sur son pas de tir où il se
détache la capsule est envoyé dans le
début de l'espace qu'on considère comme
la partie voilà on le voit sur cet
animal sur ce même de karmann à cette
infographie réalisée par phi data est ce
que la capsule pourrait ne pas
redescendre si elles étaient envoyés
avec une erreur de calcul un peu trop
loin non est ce qu'il ya un risque que
finalement ils restent là ou non aucun
c'est une question qu'on peut
légitimement se poser surtout quand on
ce genre de davrey t'en fais pas pour se
libérer de la traction au tesla la
gravité des truies et implacable il faut
attendre une certaine vitesse latéral
pas au réseau pas verticale mais
vraiment latéral d'heure le lait les
fusées d'ordinaire d'école à la
verticale mais assez rapidement dès
qu'elles ont franchi les principales
couches de l'atmosphère elle sous couche
et le but et d'attendre de la vitesse
horizontale c'est ça qui permet de
sortie de se mettre sur orbite et donc
de tourner autour et toute vitesse
verticale vous pouvez partir très vite
il fait vraiment vraiment pas très très
très vite pour arriver à vous arracher
en ligne droite de la terre et le moteur
l'acquis et qui peut la fusée n'est pas
du tout du tout du tout du tout capable
de cette performance à nokere aucun
risque mais vraiment aucun abandonné
dans le vide de l'espace
après robin film gravity oui il ne leur
arrivera pas qui est le vrai risque
c'est que le faisait exploser que le
système de secours ne marche pas mais ça
fait déjà plusieurs états diakham des
des redondances et puis après au retour
c'est voilà faut bien que les parachutes
se déploie correctement le risque est
plus de s'écraser au sol parce que les
parachutes se sont pas déclenchés comme
il le fallait que de rester perché dans
les limbes de l'espace cette fusée elle
et rieuse et beau ça veut dire qu'elle
est réutilisable ça veut dire qu'on va
se dire qu'elle revient sur terre
au même endroit que là où elle a décrit
mme louis à trois kilomètres ce qui est
par rapport à la hauteur à laquelle
elles montrent quasiment rien vous
imaginez 100 km d'autres km2 pas de côté
c'est vraiment pas grand chose donc
c'est vraiment elles partent bas elle
pas une grande parabole est le ça
ressemble vraiment plus la trajectoire
la forme de la fusée si vous voulez
quasiment les mêmes un peu plus un peu
plus allongés parce que voilà c'est les
trente fois plus haute que large 7
cette trajectoire
voilà et donc du coup ça va monter ça va
retomber c'est la troisième fois que
l'ensemble réutiliser là le couple donc
cette fusée a déjà vous allez être la
troisième fois qu'elle était la capsule
c'est la troisième fois qu'elle vols
décollent dans 15 minutes quasiment
maintenant on
on vous l'a dit cette fusée de décoller
à 15 heures heure de paris les passagers
les quatre passagers sont déjà installés
il ya un poil de retard on doit il ya
sept 7 8 secondes neuf secondes de
retard le compteur en fait du retard
s'affole un peu on va dire non mais ça
va pas c'est juste que tu as et envoie
ils ont stoppé la chronologie et il
décompte le temps depuis depuis le
moment où la chronologie a été stoppée
d'accord je ne sais pas pourquoi la
chronologie destot ps que je n'ai pas le
flic à sion je n'ai pas le retour son
rbe que on va vous le mettre les retours
sont c'est en anglais mais vous êtes
polyglotte à on voit des images
j'imagine annoncé le petit oliver damon
jeune homme qui va s'envoler qui n'a que
18 ans et voilà on voit sur ces images
fournies par blue origin
c'est l'un des quatre passagers
aujourd'hui un qui va s'envoler aux
côtés de jeff bezos c'est qui il va
devenir de fait si ce vol se passe bien
et qu'il revient le plus jeune
astronaute de l'histoire voilà on voit
ces images d'archivés qui ont été tourné
il ya quelques jours un tout l'équipage
qui se rencontrent aussi plaisante c'est
bien que l'atmosphère soit détendu dans
des moments comme ceux là lui aussi est
pilote je crois un oliver damon a passé
son brevet de pilote avant le feu avant
le l'évaluer jeune fille de 18 ans est
excessivement jeunes c'est un
voilà c'est un vol que de nombreux fans
d' espace aimerait faire d'ailleurs on
sait jeff bezos très cher branson elon
musk
ils ont l'ambition de développer le
tourisme spatial et pas qu'eux mais est
ce qu'il ya des du monde qui se bouscule
au portillon pour pour participer à ce
type de vols dans les semaines les mois
qui arrivent est ce que dans le cas de
jeff bezos ce les places sont réservées
à acheter c'est assez alors pour ce qui
est de virgin galactic
j'ai pu vivre un chiffre en être mais il
me semble qu'ils aient dit que 600
places avaient été réservés on n'a pas
le prix du ticket exact le bruit qui
courait c'était deux cent mille deux
cent cinquante mille dollars peut-être
300 mille dollars la place
mais c'est un on n'a pas de peine on n'a
pas de chiffres très exact pour ce qui
est de bourgines c'est encore plus
obscure que ça parce que officiellement
il y avait que le siège de sauvagnon
graal qui avaient été vendus l'acheteur
ministère s'est désisté pour des raisons
d'agenda 20 minutes oui le grand gagnant
de cette vente aux enchères pour cette
place aux côtés jeff bezos a finalement
il a décliné en tout cas pour ce vol là
en précisant comme vous dites que
c'était pour des raisons d'agenda
d'incompatibilité d'agendas mais ils
seront là il prend pas part à ce vol
elle est donc c'est à dire une place est
à ce moment-là blue origin a dit ah ben
on a déjà vendu une place au deuxième
haut sur la liste at deuxième
enchérisseurs et donc du coup on lui a
proposé une place sur un vol ultérieur
donc via le vol intérieur on sait pas
sur quel vol iy un calvaire des avait
vendu on sait pas quel prix on sait pas
si c'était au prix de son enchère ou
c'était un prix plus normal ce que
l'enchère principal victorieuse étaient
28 millions de dollars
le prix du ticket sur le blu-ray jean ne
sera pas à ce prix là à ce prix là ils
se priveraient semblables centaines de
milliers de dollars
mais ça ça fait les plus vendeurs qu'ils
soient alignés prêts sur le coup de
génie galactique et 200 à 300 mille
dollars
donc qui n'est pas à la portée de tout
un chacun on est d'accord n'ont peur de
rien mais bon en même temps se
démocratiser dans un moyen vers deux
possibilités soit ça soit ça fonctionne
bien c'est très fiable
les vols s'enchaînent sans problème et c
est la demande suite auquel cas
peut-être que il pourrait y avoir des
économies d'échelle mais je je je pense
que ça va être pour tout de suite
je pense pas qu'on réalise le prix par
dix très rapidement pour pas par rapport
aux technologies utilisées on le disait
le 11 juillet dernier c'est richard
branson qui a réussi et qui a damé le
pion de façon peut-être pour certains
aînés considérons que ce n'est pas très
élégant d'avoir damé le pion à jeff
bezos ce qui lui avait annoncé son
décollage ce 20 juillet et finalement
c'est richard branson qui a réussi à
faire un vol habité de quelques minutes
dans l'espace avec virgin galactic de
technologie différent je le disais
richard branson
il ya quelques jours il partait en
avions aidé par un autre avion pour
monter le plus haut possible et puis
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur une
technologie plus traditionnel avec les
moyens d'une fusée est ce qu'il ya une
technologie pour dans les dents à moyen
long terme sur ce type de vol qui sera
mieux que l'autre et qui va supplanter
l'autre bon ces jeux c'est très dur de
faire les je veux pas jouer les aux
mauvaises augures mai
la technologie choisie par richard
branson paraît beaucoup plus risqué
c'est vraiment ça demande d'ailleurs
quatre pilotes de pilote dans le
vaisseau mère de pilote dans le vaisseau
fusée c'est un vaisseau fusée qui aurait
atterri en planant qui freine avec un
patin c'est seth qui nécessite de de
deux courbes et les ailes pour pour la
retombée face et s'est beaucoup de
technologies très spectaculaire un peu
c'est un peu le rodéo quoi c'est à la
fois très malin sur le plomb de
l'aéronautique assez enthousiasmant
c'est assez joli
ils les experts pensent que c'est
probablement un peu moins fiables il ya
déjà eu un accident mortel qui a valu la
la vie à un des pilotes d'essai qui a
grièvement blessé l'autre qui a fait
sonner le glas d'ailleurs de de
l'entreprise et d'un galactique
voilà le concept de capsules
réutilisables avec cette sécurité au
décollage de pouvoir être éjecté en cas
de problème
la technologie de retour sous parachute
ça semble quand même voilà il ya des
milliers des milliers de gens qui
reviennent en parachute sur terre sans
problème ça part et ça paraît quand même
plus plus fiables après qu'est-ce qui
est le plus économique je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'on a une idée du coup
effectivement qu'on coûté ces deux
projets sap a vraiment beaucoup de sa
part ça pas vraiment de sens de parler
du coût des projets parce que ces
écoutes développement extrêmement élevé
donc forcément on peut pas facile si
vous êtes allés se veut se secoue de
développement sur 10 ans d'exploitation
font sens nombre de personnes etc
enfin vous allez avoir un prix du vol
qui complètement aléatoire
et après il ya le prix du vol proprement
dit c'est à dire le coût de remise en
état du lanceur de la capsule des
combustibles du personnel etc
donc il ya un coût fixe par lancement et
là j'ai pas du tout la réponse je sais
pas ce qui est le plus cher entre la
solution de blu-ray jean ou celle de
nous celle de virgin galactic qui a
besoin de pilotes là tout est automatisé
en même temps voilà le juge van je me
rends pas compte combien de fois on peut
réutiliser ce un lanceur comme celui-là
comme une fois on pourrait utiliser le
l'avion jeff bezos ce sans avoir à le
faire de maintenance dessus je pense que
le temps le dira dans les deux cas ce
jeu il ya des doutes quand même assez
assez importants sur la rentabilité
de ces opérations alors on voit qu'en ce
moment il ya du mouvement donc la portée
est fermé depuis maintenant quelques
minutes et on a vu du mouvement c'est à
dire que le grand escalier la grande
échelle on va dire vient de se détacher
et ce recul est de cette fusée donc un
décollage qui si on en croit le le
chronomètre ou décompte est prévu dans
sept huit minutes maintenant si on se
tient à l'horaire qui est prévu non même
ça devrait être voyez on est un peu de
retard puisqu'il est 14h57 et des
risques pris un peu de retard au monde
où l'on s'appelle premiers décomptes
voient la l2 voilà le décompte reprend
donc les huit minutes de retard gg oui
j'ai pas eu le temps de regarder tout à
l'heure mais il semble que la chrono a
repris après 5 6 minutes non oui c'est
inviter 6e 8 et 6 15
voilà quatorze 14 minutes de retard ça
va être plutôt un décollage à 15h15
15h15 donc des du retard qui est pris
pour
parce qu'on escomptait alors peut-être
que la jeune ronde intervenir et qu'on
n'entend pas peut-être l'expliqué l'a
peut-être l'information de nous nous ne
l'avons pas en tout cas c'est vraiment
rien de grave sinon il n'aurait pas
repris dans 15 des détails ça devrait
décoller on va rappeler peut-être triste
en vain c'est pas un vol très long tout
va se passer de façon assez rapide si
cette fusée décolle à 15h15
on peut estimer que ce sera terminé quoi
15h30 15 heures à 15 heures 25 15 heures
à 15 heures 25 tout sera terminé c'est à
dire que la minute sera way le oui ça ça
va ça va durer 10 minutes
ça veut dire beaucoup plus de temps
savait très rapide je pense ça va
paraître un peu plus long impôts section
dedans avec cette espèce de truc
paradoxal ça va ressembler à la fois
très court et très long je pense le
tournoi comme se dilater
parce que voilà c'est quelque chose
d'assez d'assez merveilleux à vivre je
pense pour moi voilà je vous feriez est
restée ouais alors après la capsule
je le ferai je vous mentirais en disant
que j'avais pas peur mais je crois que
le ferai
l'avion de richard branson je suis pas
sûr
parce que parce que les les après bon
s'il n'y avait pas le choix et comme j
aimerais sebrango rien je vais
maintenant je sais pas ce que je savais
pas ce que vous feriez je ferai
peut-être que j'irai quand même c'est
l'opportunité d'une vie en même temps
voilà je crois que j'aurai toujours eu
très peur j'aurais très peur je serai
plus rassuré dans ce dans cette capsule
qui finalement un espèce d'ascension
spécial c'est plus comme un gros tour de
manège l'autre c'est vraiment plus un
type de pilote d'essai quoi donc vous
dit un grand tour de manège alors
effectivement il ya de nombreux
détracteurs à ses vols c'est tourisme
spatial que seuls certains milliardaires
peuvent s'offrir qui est aussi initié
par par des milliardaires
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
considèrent qu' on ne va pas jouer comme
ça dans l'espace que il faut considérer
que seule la science peut y aller et que
c'est tourisme spatial qui est initié
aujourd'hui qu'il a été la semaine
dernière avec richard branson va être la
porte ouverte a dû à des excès je pense
que c'est uniquement aux plus grandes
fortunes mondiales
il ya plusieurs manières de répondre à
ça déjà oui ça va être accessible qu'aux
plus riches pour l'instant mais comme
beaucoup de choses dans le monde et sur
terre soit kivu plus riches
voilà les lamborghini ses accès qu'aux
plus riches bon ben c'est c'est un peu
comme ça c'est enfin la question de
débord du spatial du cadre du spatial et
on pourrait en débattre pendant des
heures mais c'est un faux procès ensuite
l'idée de dire que que ces polluants que
c'est une activité qui ne devrait pas
exister et c'est même dans 80 des
galactiques que ça me paraît pas très
pertinent alors que c'est un certain
très polluants certains estiment que
l'argent pourrait être mis ailleurs
justement c'est le rêve de toute façon
écologique c'est vrai de tous c'est le
débat me paraît il on regarde le budget
de l'armée américaine sur une année on
regarde tout ce qu'on pourrait faire
avec voilà c'est effarant mais le monde
est ainsi fait il voit là puis cessé il
ya des raisons complexes pour lesquels
les chaussons ce sont comme ça voilà
lassé des milliardaires qui dépensent
leur argent comme il en a envie et pour
faire des choses auxquelles il croit et
ça me paraît pas du tout répréhensible
ensuite il convient de répondre à ça
c'est que le fait d'aller dans l'espace
c'est aussi une excellente manière tous
les astronautes qui sont allés dans
l'espace ont rapporté avoir ressenti la
fragilité de la terre son aspect fini le
se sentir une petite chose à côté de ça
il décrypte une expérience relativement
métaphysique s'appelle overview effects
et ça a été théorisé le fait un de se
détacher avant de cette planète qu'on
voit de l'extérieur comme une petite
comme quelque chose de finale 2-2
terriblement fini dans l'immense et du
cosmos ça a été un déclic pour plein
l'astronaute et tous les astronomes par
exemple mis vite assez activement pour
le réchauffement climatique quel que
soit l'ordre à pesqué en première ligne
bien puisqu'un première ligne quel que
soit leur bord politique leur leurs
idées préconçues leur origine
géographique qu'ils soient russes texan
démocrates républicains favoris c'est
quelque chose partagé par vraiment tous
les astronautes ce sentiment de finitude
et on peut se dire que voilà où le
tourisme de des riches pourra être un
déclic aussi sur ceux sur ce plan là
donc pourquoi pas et ce sera forcément
un nombre de vols relativement limité
c'est pas une activité justement parce
qu'elle est très soit elle est très cher
et les limites et soual est beaucoup
moins chère elle ouverte à tous donc
l'un dans l'autre je pense que le sait
un peu c'est un peu un faux débat alors
après je comprends que les gens voient
une forme d'indécence dans le fait
d'avoir des des fortunes aussi grande
comme ça qu'ils vont dépenser des
milliards pour aller faire quelque chose
qui peut paraître insignifiante mais je
j'ai un peu de mal avec cette idée là
parce que c'est il ya tellement de
manières plus futiles de dépenser son
argent et blue origin c'est une
entreprise qui hantent qui emploie plein
de gens qui installée au texas qui
bénéficient de cet argent fait agir
c'est cccc pas de l'argent dépensé comme
un caprice quoi c'est eux c'est vrai
c'est des entreprises et qu'on peut des
dizaines de personnes qui développent
des technologies qui font rêver les gens
non ça ne fait pas aimé ça fait rêver
certains lots big de tout ça c'est pas
je ne sais pas comment dire c'est pas
d'aller d'aller polluer l'espace quoi
c'est vraiment juste d'aller voir de là
c'est la curiosité quoi voilà c'est il
ya une forme de curiosité derrière ça
je trouve ça dur de dire aux gens ouais
vous avez tort d'être curieux voilà je
sais pas ma manière de voir les choses
je vous mentirais en tant que moi
personnellement le tourisme spatial
même si j'aimerais bien faire un tour là
haut voilà ça me ça me passionne pas non
plus de manière incroyable quoi mais ça
me versement ça me me révoltent pas que
des gens aient envie de monter sur mon
entreprise ça d'aller explorer au delà
de l atmosphère
nous sommes en direct sur figaro live
nous le sommes également sûr sur youtube
pour vous faire vivre ce décollage de
jeff bezos ce à bord de sa propre fusée
douché par blue origin il devrait il
aurait dû déjà décollé les 15 heures 4
et 5 secondes il a un peu de retard jeff
bezos s'est en tout cas ça faisait un
peu de retard et les équipes qui
travaillent avec lui
vous le voyez il ya le conteur qui
s'affiche à l'image elle devrait
décoller maintenant cette fusée dans
moins de huit minutes
vous êtes d'ailleurs un certain nombre
et dont
brian pertes et sur youtube qui
s'interroge pourquoi il est 15h et
pourquoi elle ne décolle pas cette fusée
il doit y avoir quelques contretemps
inhérents la préparation de cette fusée
et aux quelques minutes qui qui précède
un décollage qui font qu'il ya ce retard
djoko ce nous demandent est-ce qu'ils
vont filmer depuis l'intérieur de la
capsule jeu je présume cependant on n'a
pas vu d'image de l'intérieur voilà je
sais pas quelles sont les capacités de
de transmission en direct de ce qui se
passe d'un visuels fournis par blue
origin mais ça n'est pas ce qui se passe
en ce moment dans la capsule
mais oui je pense qu'il y aura
possiblement des imaginales pense qu'il
n'a pas il ya peut-être aussi des envies
d'en faire une expérience est un petit
peu plus intime personnel qu'on voit pas
si petits qu'ils sont stressés qu'ils
ont peur que l'origine est peut-être
dans un certain contrôle de sa
communication et préfère a montré des
images qu'elle a bien revu validé pour
être super forme suivi le décollage de
thomas pesquet et un à bord de cette
petite capsule
dragon's si je me trompe ou dragonne
voilà on coud dragonne on n'avait pas vu
les images de l'équipage au moment du
décollage et de ce qui avait été dit à
l'époque dans les commentaires officiels
c'est que les familles ne souhaitait pas
que s'il y avait un souci on voit la
mort en direct de leurs proches
oui ça c'est toujours c'est toujours un
petit peu délicat de diffuser mais mais
mais dans la coudre agon il diffuse
avant et après au moment où il
commençait à prendre un peu de hauteur
il diffuse déjà des images relativement
direct la voilà encore une fois je ne
sais pas le blues dinah une à une
culture de communication très assez
opaque ins et c'est vraiment une
entreprise un peu à l'ancienne
on n'est pas du tout dans le mode start
up hyper énergique avec des hordes de
fans de space x couac est très moderne
comme peut-être pour le meilleur et pour
le pire mais parfois pour le meilleur et
brassé quelque chose de beaucoup plus
secret voilà il ya une conférence de
presse que d'organiser là
le ya deux jours avant le lancement
voilà il est pas jeff bezos s'est pas
son père son frère y avait pas le jeune
n'y avait pas le l'astronaute donc bon
c'est un peu surprenant quoi il y avait
le 6 oct personne ne connaît une chef
des astronautes
la responsable du marketing les
questions étaient hyper bordés c'était
que des médias américains
clairement on sentait que les questions
avaient été avaient été revus avant et
quand les questions de déborder un tout
petit peu ou poser des questions dans un
tout petit peu dérangeante on va dire il
n'y avait aucune réponse était la langue
de bois la plus totale aucune
communication sur le déroulement du vol
vraiment quelque chose de très très
aseptisé
voilà assez loin de la culture du
spatial finalement
la nasa a une grande volonté de
transparence
les astronautes sont son moi là sont
vraiment mis à la disposition du public
on sait tous le commentaire tous les
lancements se font en direct avec des
commentaires on a on entend tout ce qui
se passe dans la salle de contrôle s'est
des problèmes en direct on sait voilà
c'est une culture alors c'était ces
curieuses que vous dites puisque s'il ya
bien quelqu'un qui est désormais proche
est partenaire de la nasa c'est bien
lots de masques
mais du coup l anneau est ce qu'un peu à
dd qui fait des choses en personne avec
la nasa s'est complètement ouvert pour
ce qui est des vols commerciaux
c'est un peu plus c'est un peu plus
fermées en amont il ya moins
d'informations alors maintenant qu'ils
sont entrés en quelque chose d'un peu
plus routinier il ya un peu plus de on
attendait on a des timeline 2
de vol etc il ya quand même des des
éléments et puis assez rapidement après
les lancements il ya quand même pas mal
de assez rapidement des vidéos même les
échecs sont montrés par space x et mis
en scène
oui n'hésite pas et donne mascara brisé
en fait et à faire se détruire ça
devient après cette starship sont pas
forcément diffusé en direct par space x
mais il a une communauté de fans qui
voulaient film au téléobjectif de très
loin et les diffuser sur internet et il
admet ce qui n'empêche pas du tout ça de
se produire si sa salsa le cercle c'est
à la nuit tombée et j'ai investi qui est
investi dans la voiture électrique et au
soutien d'une démonstration qu'il a
lui-même fait d'une voiture blindée qui
devait résister à des projectiles puis
s'en est finalement qu il ya rater
totalement direct et ses coups de
marteau à des services ont la promotion
du véhicule en question
nous sommes en direct sur figaro là il
pour vous faire vivre maintenant dans 3
minutes 20
si tout va bien le décollage jeff bezos
saborde de sa fusée fusée qui doit
partir et décoller depuis son pâtira van
oord au texas à la frontière avec le
mexique
donc nous sommes aux états unis vous
voyez ces images fournies par blue
origin qui est la société fondée par
jeff bezos ce justement pour permettre
le développement des vols d
spatiaux de tourisme pour les touristes
fortunés qui souhaiteront s'envoler dans
l'espace quelques minutes puisque on le
rappelle tristan ce vol va durer
quelques minutes à peine et les quatre
passagers qui sont installés depuis près
de trois quarts d'heure dans cette
capsule perché au sommet de la fusée et
bien et nous profiterons de cette de
l'espace et de la vision qu'ils auront
de la courbe de la courbure de la terre
que 3 4 minutes à peine avant de revenir
sur terre on va le vivre ensemble dans 2
minutes 30
c'est de ce décollage avec cette petite
fusée vous disiez tristan une fusée de
taille petite rapport à celle fournie
par elon musk la nasa habituellement me
marianne
oui c'est une petite fusée a fait 15 m
donc voilà comme je disais c'est la
taille d'un immeuble haussmannien à peu
près c'est ça n'a rien à voir avec les
70 m de la falaise nine le spectre 6000
cm d'ariane 5
voilà je parle même pas de saturn 5 qui
de faire faire 80 ou 100 m alors elle
décolle pas encore à la fusée c'est
juste la caméra qui bouge parce que la
lettre accueillir qui ce recul on voit
que il ya encore quelques branchements
qui vont se détacher presque des câbles
une alimentation toute l'électronique et
le fait qu'on peut demander à raphaël de
monter un peu le son du retour afin
qu'on entende les échanges radio il aura
beaucoup de poussière parce que c'est un
sol très poussiéreux dans le coin mais
c'est ça va pas être la violence d'un
décollage d'ariane 5 par exemple d'une
falcon c'est ça fait plus un peu allez
on va laisser les bleus ont va laisser
vivre ces images sans les commenter pour
que l'émotion soit à son paroxysme avant
ce décollage attendu le verdict non
éliminatoire
la russie dit
[Musique]
kim ngan culture
dimanche barrait et c'est pareil pour le
magazine star to one
[Musique]
matthew barnaby freeangel midi libre à
vous tous ici
or elle communique aux mines est encore
à sa parution en bacs ou entre amis
ennuyant
owens à prévenir
une star ici
enrico cette expérience vous êtes à dire
que la viande est en train de voir la
séparation de la capsule et de la fusée
la fusée qui monte très vite jusqu'à
dépasser cette fameuse ligne inquiets
c'est par l'atmosphère de l'espace
on entend en sont une partie des
réactions de l'équipage ses quatre
passagers dont jeff bezos ce qu'ils
viennent de vivre cet événement en
direct
voilà
vous diffuse en ce moment juste en ces
jours les essais de et de ses passagers
qu'on entend la de redescendre à grande
vitesse sont encore en zéro g ils vont
bientôt devoir
remettre leur ceinture je pense alors on
n'a pas les images de l'intérieur de la
capsule bizarrement alors que ce sont
des images fournies par blue origin qui
est la société
je disais ça me donne pas plus que ça je
pense qu'ils vont l'aider yvon les les
diffuseront ensuite je pense qu'ils
préfèrent contrôler l'espace de deir
défense donc la fusée va se poser à
quelques kilomètres du pas de tir bout
elle a décollé voilà on voit des images
depuis la france est depuis la fusée la
booster n'a pas d'image depuis
l'intérieur de la capsule il se trouve
jeff bezos smart grid os le jeune homme
de 18 ans est la pire la pilote
chevronné de 82 ans
wally funk et oliver damon qui sont avec
jeff bezos s'ils sont donc quatre
passagers à vivre ce premier vol habité
et blue origin
on les sent heureux un an les encore il
a plaidé mourad de plaisir et de
satisfaction
la mission n'est pas encore acheté un
tristan et il faut qu'ils touchent terre
pour que ce soit terminé
là on voit le le booster et la capsule
qui serait l'une de l'autre
le booster qui redessine shirt clairs
qui va rallumer son son moteur pourrait
tenter de se poser en douceur
on rappelle qu'ils sont arrivés jusqu'à
100 kilomètres de haut avant de
redescendre un peu plus sous l a350 1000
pieds exactement voilà cette fusée qui
redescend
elle sera suivie par la capsule qui elle
sera freinée par trois parachutes
du coup un peu plus de temps à retomber
jusqu'au sol
c'est un moment aussi un peu apeurée un
peu risqué atterrissage
oui sa mise et c'est risqué pour le la
fusée a presque que du matériel moment
très délicat de ce retour de la fusée
qui devrait atterrir maintenant et
revenir sur terre à quelques kilomètres
de l'endroit d'où elle à défaut les
nocéens possible donc on va savoir s'il
est réussi ou pas d'à priori réussi
telle que les presque au milieu avant de
la cimade et faisait atterrir ça me
c'est tintin quoi alors voici la capsule
maintenant qui devrait déclencher ces
parachutes avant de se poser au sol dans
laquelle se trouve donc 4 est bien celle
d'une plus grande baisse
il a rappelé à vous pensez à jeff bezos
ce que savoir si sa fusée a atterri
choisissez d'abord est le cadet de ses
soucis à ce moment là mais je pense que
vraiment là il est plus concentré sur je
pense sont
son expérience d'achat ils ont dû
freiner pas mal déjà des grossistes ont
fait quelques jets on les entend plus
trop comment vous faites sur internet
évidemment vous êtes effectivement
impressionné comme nous sommes nous
mêmes
et voilà des dentiers parachute là
guillaume t qui nous dit que c'est
impressionnant effectivement c'est très
impressionnant ce qu'on vient de voir
qui se sont ouverts pour ralentir la
deuxième capsule des rétrofusées aussi
de dépenser vous nous préciser christian
principe juste avant deux dates et les
magnifiques images de ce retour sur
terre d'une cape ce rebond qui a permis
à ses passagers de d'aller toucher du
doigt l'espace au dessus de nos têtes
très impressionnant de cet événement
pour replanter besançon imagine le voilà
où il a encore touché terre mais là tout
se passe comme ça tu l'avais souhaité
voilà il peut plus vraiment des choses
là le pire qui puisse se passer c'est
que il touche le sol un petit peu fort
mais ils sont attachés à leur si elle
s'est lâchée alors comme il s'y serait
ce serait comme je sais pas comment
alors j'imagine que on n'a pas les
images là de ce qui se passe dans la
capsule mais possiblement qu'elles sont
enregistrés pour pour eux
ils auront ils se sont filmés
et que peut-être ces images seront
divulgués ultérieurement oui je pensais
passer très rapidement je veux pas
vraiment d'intérêt de faire de la
rétention de ce genre d'image très
longuement après comme c'est jeff bezos
si le contrôler son image et que du coup
il veut il va attendre de valider les
vidéos qui ont été prises en vue d'un
drone côté passé à côté
bah oui je pense qu'ils vont après
mettre en scène tout se vole oui ils
vont faire probablement un film
hollywoodien voilà ce à quoi je suis tu
je sais pas c'est pas de moi car
atterrissait un petit peu plusieurs ce
qu'il imaginait et voilà ils sont
arrivés à bon port un atterrissage
réussi pour new shepard l'origine la
fusée qui est revenu là où elle devait
se poser la capsule également qui a été
ralenti par ces trois énormes parachute
avec à son bord ses quatre passagers
jeff bezos smart bo son frère cadet wali
phone 7 pilotes de 82 ans qui avait
toujours rêvé d'aller dans l'espace avec
la nasa et qui a jamais pu faire et puis
ce jeune homme de 18 ans qui arrivera
bien un nom qui à l'extrême chance la
grande chance de pouvoir voler
aujourd'hui est d'aller dans l'espace le
plus jeune quart chronique désormais
l'art de l'histoire spatiale l'intérieur
qu'ils ont fait était trop secouer à
l'atterrissage je suis partagé
on a senti que ça paie alors il ya au
bout juste pour répondre même si c'est
une question à laquelle on a déjà
répondu
75e c'est sur le chat du figaro vous
demande tristan à partir de quelle
altitude on peut considérer qu'on est
dans l'espace donc oui j'ai pas fini les
excuses à leurs les calculs au début
vont montrer qu'on pouvait définir une
limite ou l'effritement de l'air
devenait de négliger à peu près à 50
miles donc ce qui correspond à 80 km
c'est la limite qui a été franchi par
richard branson on essaie de 83 km
c'était c'était une altitude
mais après voilà 400 km la science
spatiale internationale est encore
ralentie par les frottements de l'air
même très heavy duels et au delà 30 km
on commence à voir le noir de l'espace
au dessus de soi il n'y a pas de
frontières bien définis quoi le
l'atmosphère c'est une fine couche de
gaz après se dilue progressivement et
elle s'étend sans réel sans réelles
limites qu'on va trouver des atomes de
d'atmosphère un peu partout alors on
s'interroge évidemment comme anonymes 57
130 qui s'interroge y sont conscients
les passagers parce que c'est vrai qu'on
a la pression
c'est un mannequin immobile derrière ce
hiblot d'un mètre par 70 on voit pas
beaucoup de mouvements dans cette
capsule
moi je pense qu'ils doivent être encore
voit effectivement quelqu'un derrière la
vitre qui regarde il regarde dehors ils
devaient être arrachés je ne sais pas
très bien quelle mesure ils peuvent se
c'est après ceux qui peuvent se en
valeur leur ceinture et de la pesanteur
personne ne vient de rouvrir la porte
moi je pense que les en fait y'a aucun
risque est pris quoi ya pas vraiment de
ils sont pas en danger il appert
carburant là dans la capsule donc le
bras yaoi absolument aucun danger
les voitures de récupération avec un peu
plus éloignée une descente sous
parachute comme ça n'est pas contrôlée
donc on tombe pas exactement on sait pas
exactement à l'avancé on va tomber
enfin pas 50 pas à 500 mètres près et
donc et donc du coup bah voilà les
équipes de récupération vont arriver la
différence par rapport à un retour
d'astronautes c'est qu'ils ont passé un
temps très bref en apesanteur
c'est comme quand vous atterrissez voilà
les véhicules qui viennent les récupérer
c'est comme quand vous atterrissez jeu
peu après après un voyage en avion via
yahia vous n'êtes pas vraiment besoin
des deux voilà les gens ont leur ouvrait
la porte mais je pense qu'il pourrait
presque l'ouvrir de même de l'intérieur
le problème est que les astronautes qui
va passer longtemps dans l'espace en
apesanteur et du coup ils sont très
faibles
ils ont perdu en masse musculaire la
gravité leur paraît insoutenable et ils
tiennent à peine debout là on n'est pas
du tout du tout dans cette configuration
là
voilà je pense qu'ils sont allongés de
discuter entre eux leur expérience je
pense qu'ils doivent être encore raphaël
de nous mettre en place une chose si
c'est possible
[Musique]
qui à part ça tout le monde a l'air de
lever le pouce pour dire que tout va
bien se fait un peu dans une sorte de
précipitation fait curieux comme si bien
que ses patrons que j'abhorre oui alors
quelqu'un sont les mallettes heures avec
des gîtes y ont peut-être ils ont l'air
de se dépêcher un essai qui revient sept
7 mois je pense que l'empressement cet
empressement c'est tout juste s'il faut
pas qu'il reste trop longtemps dans la
dans la capsule ce que je pense que
encore une fois un seul patron saveurs
patrons ils sont filmés et je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément conscience de
l'image que ça peut rendre de
l'extérieur voilà avec toute ma candeur
non mais vous avez raison c'est je pense
qu'en termes de communication c'est
c'est pas une bonne idée de
de montrer autant impression ça donne
l'illusion qu'il ya une urgence à la
fois que je pensais vraiment pas le cas
après je veux j'espère que j'espère que
je me trompe pas il ya donc les
internautes en quelques formules un peu
un peu humoristique sur voilà il ya le
cric
ils ont bien le tournevis
voilà ça semble par en dessous est
effectivement l'impression qu'ils aient
beaucoup de beaucoup d'outils
nécessaires à l'ouverture de cette
capsule
et alors
le rapace
pour l'instant savoir qu'une capsule
qu'on récupère en mer ou qu'on récupère
au sol est désastreuse d'abord l'art de
la récupération est beaucoup plus
laborieuse est longue
parce qu'il faut passive et notamment
pour être sûr qu'il n'y a pas de de
fuite de carburant classique escale et
sans combinaison
ça peut durer un quart d'heure vingt
minutes qui sort de la capsule ou que fo
là c'est relativement rapide
on voit jeff bezos ça je pense que celui
qu'on voit le premier sur le premier
bouazzi blot qui lève à plusieurs cas
levé à plusieurs reprises alors ça va
faire la différence comme ça avec la wii
avec son frère lui bloqué alors c'est
pas si la capsule a eu le bon goût de le
mettre devant les caméras ou cd caméras
qui sont les semelles de vent dans le
dos en tout cas c'est son frère semble
aller plutôt bien pour eux à l'intérieur
voilà ici on réussit à priori mais on va
avoir les mots probablement de jeff
bezos de lui même au sortir de cette
capsule voile réussi décollage vol aller
retour sur terre réussi de ce qu'on a pu
voir et vous faire vivre en direct cette
dure aux sur le chat du figaro nous
demande effectivement on a parlé des
plumes noires qui le symbole de blue
origin est ce que c'est une explication
à cette vous connaissez cette origine de
cette plume c'est une bonne question je
j'ai pas la réponse à cette cette
question n'est pas là possiblement alors
n'importe 5 enfin grosse excitation sur
place et oui c'est d'être des os qui
sera le premier avec un stetson sur la
tête
oliver damon jeunes astronautes de 18
ans plus jeune astronaute de l'histoire
bien qu'elle est désormais suivi par
ouali fun que sept pilotes émérites de
82 ans qui avait toujours rêvé de partir
dans l'espace et qui a réalisé son rêve
aujourd'hui
et puis clôture que la marche c'est lé
frère de jeff bezos smart bezos qui a
participé à sauver le côté de son frère
il était donc 4 pour une non plus je
crois permettait le vol de six personnes
directement la femme de jeff bezos ce
convoi salué le jeune homme de 18 ans sa
nouvelle compagne je salue se sont
mariés ils connaissance gauche rappelle
que nous sommes au texas pour le port de
ces stetson la frontière avec le mexique
donc à côté de john horn imagine que les
ambitions de jeff gazier si on trouvait
ça n'est pas simplement de favoriser et
de développer le tourisme dans l'espace
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure l'idée
d'une exploration humaine de de notre
galaxie et au delà peut-être d'autres
calamités pas jusque là d'aller d'aller
comment dire s'installer sur sur mars en
tout cas de faire s'installer des
humains sur mars
quelle est l'ambition de bell est pas
parfaitement clair mais il y avait des
velléités de
des looney soeur et d'exploitation des
ressources lunaires
il ya cette idée que les ressources sur
terre sont finies il faut rapidement les
effets des ressources ailleurs c'est ça
qui sait sa vision je suis pas certain
qu'il ait pour ambition de la deûle a
réalisé lui-même mais d'apporter sa
pierre
je pense qu'ils croient profondément que
la conquête spatiale sera fait partie
aujourd'hui des des frontières et des
limites qu'il faut qu'il faut repousser
il a envie de s'engager là dedans le
tourisme spatial est un peu une on va
dire une étape préliminaire
il ya une fusée news glenn qui ans qui
devrait voler l'année prochaine qui bien
bien plus puissante que ce petit nul
chez verdi qui aura vocation à faire
soit des lancements des lancements
orbitaux avec des grosses capacités de
lancement avec la même volonté
probablement que qui est venu masque de
mettre en place pour commencer des
constellations pour le pour l'internet
haut débit de depuis l'espace avec voilà
tout tout le savoir-faire d'amazones en
termes de serveurs de stockage
de données etc et voilà pour le futur je
sais pas exactement 6 e s comme
l'origine a vocation à perdurer ou non
ce qu'ils seront rentables avec tourisme
spatial je ne pense pas est ce qu'ils
seront rentables avec new glen on verra
ce qu'ils vont souffrir de la
concurrence de space x c'est déjà le cas
puisque le finalement le contrat pour la
lune is her été renforcée par space x
alors que l'origine est à l'origine avec
la nasa avec la nasa un très très gros
contrat on sait d'ailleurs qu'ils
encourent
l'épisode qui a ouvert le cas sabrer le
champagne et qui est donc en là ce sont
frères et
une partie des passagers qui ont voyagé
avec lui je vous ai coupé triste enjeux
monétaires non il y avait pas de jeu
voilà je sais pas exactement quel sera
l'avenir de blue origin voilà au delà de
la 2e
de ses débuts dans le tourisme spatial
on verra on verra avec le temps bloody
nabla a pris son temps pour faire les
choses
mais hier très classique très propre et
ce que face à un concurrent aussi
fantasque que elon musk beaucoup plus
visionnaires bien meilleurs ingénieurs
et peut-être voilà est-ce que la leyre
laudine risque d'être un puits un puits
puits sans fond en terme de rentrées
d'investissement après voilà il il a
l'argent bien sûr il a l'argent pour le
faire tout dépendra du quel point il a
envie de persévérer dans ce domaine
alors qu'on vient de voir la joie
extrême un des walis funk sept pilotes
chevronnés de 82 ans qui a pu enfin
réaliser son rêve d'aller dans l'espace
et ce rêve réalisé grâce à jeff bezos
s'est aujourd'hui vous avez pu vivre en
direct sur figaro live cet événement
historique on peut le dire de ce premier
vol habité
organisé par par jeff bezos ce via son
sa société blue origin est donc ce
vaisseau spatial miu shepard qui a
décollé comme convenu aujourd'hui et
dont le vol s'est parfaitement réalisé
décollage de la fusée séparation de la
fusée et de la capsule avec à son bord
ses quatre passagers
et puis retour tranquillement sur terre
pour cette fusée et qui est revenu à
quelques kilomètres de du pas de tir se
poser doucement et on a pu assister
aussi au retour sur terre de cette
capsule frais départ trois parachutes
monumentaux et un atterrissage un peu
rude mais finalement tout va bien on le
voit sur ces images grand succès grande
satisfaction de jeff bezos ses équipes
vous avez pu vivre ce direct et vous
avez été enthousiastes comme nous
l'avons été alors pour pour comprendre
pour revoir ces images ces décollages
cet atterrissage et
le replay de cette émission est
les images seront accessibles sur le
site du figaro via figaro live et puis
vous avez également la possibilité de
voir le découpage de ce vol historique
en images de synthèse une un travail
remarquable effectué par figues dattes à
les équipes de figues dattes à
disponible en ligne sur le site du
figaro si raphaël lazreg peut nous
remontrer voilà cette animation réalisée
par phi data et ses équipes de la façon
dont s'est passé ce vol
avec de l'interactivité quand vous
passerez votre souris sur les éléments
qu'on voyait apparaître vous avez toutes
les explications pour comprendre comment
techniquement tout ceci s'est passé
voilà la séparation de la capsule et de
la fusée
magnifique travail et puis si vous
voulez en apprendre plus comme nous l'a
présenté tristan veille à quelques
minutes du duel entre elon musk et puis
jeff bezos s'est bien je vous en vous
renvoie sur la lecture de cet article
ce papier formidable de véronique
guillermard notre consoeur du figaro
spécialiste d'aéronautique en ligne
depuis ce matin bezos ce masque un duel
spatiale encore déséquilibré
voilà je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis en direct sur figaro l'arrivée
sur youtube merci beaucoup tristan vais
pour votre expérience et vos
explications vos lumières sur ce sujet
je vous laisse
et je vous dis à très vite sur figaro
live pour d'autres commentaires sur
l'actif